the jurgen experience my balls was hot
one was the famous one
i don't remember that
so how's things man things been crazy
i can only imagine yeah after that knock
out of curtis blades
like uh i mean that that got a lot of
attention
oh yeah yeah and it felt real great
good to knock him out because he was
talking a lot of trash before the fight
isn't that like par for the course
though everybody talks [ __ ] before the
fight um
even whenever i'm doing good though he's
been talking at least three years now
he's been talking mess to me
really yeah do you take that [ __ ]
personally
um i do because i'm not in there trying
to sell tickets don't just
come to me try to sell tickets to talk
trash you know i'll take everything
personal
yeah some guys do just try to sell
tickets and then they
they'll say it's not personal it's just
like
when khabib nurmagomedov was [ __ ] up
conor when he's on top of him pounding
on him going let's talk now
let's talk now remember that yeah yeah
and he goes it's just business
you know it's like this is not business
no no i go into every fight like life or
death
and i go i enter a deep dark place every
time i
step inside the octagon so it's not
business for me
what was interesting is after the fight
i mean it was just such a spectacular
knockout but after the fight you were so
nonchalant
you were just so relaxed and you're like
i couldn't get started in there and
everybody's like
what the [ __ ] are you talking about you
couldn't get started you just it was one
of the most spectacular knockouts in the
history of the heavyweight division
and you're like i couldn't get started
yeah um so
i went back home and got my blood and
everything tested
and my t levels was like in the 300s
so i had very low t so it's like i mean
testosterone yes
you have low testosterone yes that's
ridiculous
yeah i would never if you had if i was
going to make a bet
it's so like i try to spend all my
energy on my wife so it's kind of hard
because
if i don't have the energy for her then
she'll think i'm out there messing
around and stuff like that so
do they know why your testosterone was
low um
maybe over trained or something no i
don't we we don't know yet so i want to
go to another doctor that the lady was
just telling me about
oh wow that's crazy so that's why
you felt lethargic yes yes it was like
that all week so i
at first i was i thought it was the jet
lag or something like that but
it ended up just me my t levels
that was like one of the most perfectly
timed uppercuts i've ever seen
it was perfect yeah we practiced that
for the last few months
so that was the game plan when he shoots
to catch him coming in yes
either the knee or the uppercut um we
knew he was going to be there we knew he
was going to try to play the game
try to stand up for a little bit and the
way he shoots
he don't really shoot like um a real
wrestler he shoots like from the hip
down
and coming like that he doesn't bend the
knee and try to come in
hmm that's interesting so
he goes he hinges he goes forward yes
why do you think he does that
um i don't know i don't know you know
because usually the wrestler they drop a
knee then shoots
yeah but he just bend down and i'm
guessing he's just trying to grab my leg
to pick it up or something like that i
don't know
so how did you get involved in fighting
what was your first experiences
first experience was like because
everyone knew i loved fighting in the
streets
like every weekend at parties and stuff
like that and so one of my friends that
told me
um about mma and i was like i didn't
really know anything about mma at the
time
and watch videos this is like 10 years
ago did you have any martial arts
training at all no i don't
i i still don't have any martial arts
of course you do your professional
martial arts i'm watching youtube videos
now so
i'm learning some stuff now really yeah
you're not you're not [ __ ] around
like really you learn from youtube
videos i learn
i learn from my coach as well but i
watch youtube videos and stuff like that
too
so 10 years ago you had no martial arts
training at all
no martial art training and where did
you first start training
i just started training at a gym called
silverback mma
and so this was 10 years ago you just
decided to learn were you thinking about
being a professional were you just doing
it for fun um
they say that back then i thought like
500 500 was pretty good money you know
so they're saying that you can get paid
on 500 um just three rounds or three
minutes
i said just three minutes i didn't think
three minutes was a long time until i
got in
there it's like damn okay
and so we just started training from
there though and i fell in love with it
so it's to me it's almost like street
fighting so it's like yeah i could do
that
but one of the things that's changed
about you over the years
is your endurance your endurance is it
it came up in a big way
like you can see in the gabriel gonzaga
fight you can see in a lot of your
fights like you can
you can put pressure on people now and
and you have a lot of high volume
with which in the beginning of your
career i think you had a harder time
with
oh yeah and so that's really what we
focus on now at um
main street boxing gym is my
conditioning
and my endurance and stuff like that
because we feel like that's the only
weakness
in my game right now yeah but it's like
you're so big
i don't even know if it's a weakness i
think it's just part of being a giant
person
you know yeah but the travis brown
fights another example
like that was a crazy fast-paced fight
but
you you know you overwhelmed him yeah
yeah um i love that fight too before the
this this past fight with occurred it
was one of my favorite
and that that week
going into travis brown fight i took
some laxatives um just try to help me
cut some weight but you know i took it
that wednesday and you're still
lingering around so it's like man he
kicked me in my body but he also broke
my ribs but i also did have to take a
[ __ ]
so i wasn't lying about that so yeah
that was a ridiculous interview though
yeah that fight was uh that was that was
a heavy duty fight
there's a lot of bad blood in that fight
too right yes and
ever since then like whenever i do my um
you know how they come in a few days
before the commentators try to talk to
you
and ever since then i stopped telling
the guys
what's my game plan and stuff like that
because i didn't know
him and brian staying at the time was
friends
and so our game plan was to come in
and try to um to kick his legs because
he used to stand real wide
but whenever me and him fought he didn't
stand like that at all
like not one time so you think brian
stan went to him and told him i believe
so i believe so
yeah yeah yeah that's kind of dirty
yeah yeah yeah so and he didn't tell you
his strategy
no he didn't damn brian's damn so
i'm just believe that's that was the
case
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download
episodes to save on data cost all for
free
spotify is absolutely free you don't
have to have a premium account to watch
new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience